is this the end for liquid in Katowice I
lose 32 kills to his name's gonna add
another one with two this could be all
she wrote for liquid twenty seconds left
we chipped in for a third and are not a
likely powerhouse I was coming back to
Finland and he's gonna stop it it's
gonna make ends good again but really
most people fault they're not gonna do
much because the squad didn't before
they started out as a joke but against
every odd they became not only major
finalists but one of the best teams in
the world leaves a Drennen of one versus
three year to try and keep the dream
alive and I'm not sure that's gonna be
possible he goes down 16 to 9 in favor
of ents taking down phase at this point
and RCS goes newest rockstars they have
their very own copy pasta hence is
coming easy for NS their own theme song
[Music]
which has even been added to the csgo
client I have no idea what the [ __ ] they
say in that music it but that wasn't
always the case in fact for a very very
long time
things were anything but easy friends
[Music]
now in order to understand just how
unlikely and it's a sudden rise to
stardom was we need to go back in time a
little bit the year is 2014 and are
playing against ninjas in pyjamas as the
copenhagen games now not only are knit
one of the greatest csgo teams in the
world at that time they're also the
pride and joy of sweden a country which
despite being spitting distance away
from Finland has always outclassed their
neighbour in counter-strike
to put it simply and are getting [ __ ] on
they are down 13:3 and to top it all off
this happens there we go and then
someone just explained to me what just
genuinely happy because I think we've
just have the shortest ever round in the
history of compared to countless strike
global offensive nine seconds that's how
long it took for a nip to dumpster ends
and in case you're wondering it's
actually the second shortest round of
csgo but don't worry we'll get to the
actual shortest one in just a bit
founded in 2013 ends with Finland's best
effort to rival their Scandinavian
neighbours in csgo
the problem is that they weren't just
awful by Scandinavian standards they
were awful by any standard let's put it
this way
it took nearly five and a half years to
make their first top eight finish at a
premier event
honestly Finnish counter-strike used to
be a big thing but then which is absent
for like a decade
it took us a couple tries but finally
we're getting there obviously being a
long line now it just so happens that
two of the players who receive that
vicious beat-down from nip are important
figures in the unlikely story of ences
ascension the first is all it will get
to allah and the other the guy we're
gonna focus on right now is not to who
in many ways is the man behind ends his
recent success not to his goal has
always been to put finnish CS on the map
a 1.6 a legend he spent most of his
global offensive career with you guessed
it and
[Applause]
Gilliam but it's gonna be not see with
this close to not too hot he's gotta go
point Blake finds the third flag
finally in 2015 not to retired but he
was still held bent on proving that
finished CS could compete so in 2016
after trying out as both a coach and a
caster he finally rejoined ends but this
time in a managerial role going back all
the way into 2016 it was like main goal
when we first started we kind of shrug
right we wanted to bring the feeling
back on day well the major level right
the thing is even with not to behind the
scenes and still wasn't doing
particularly well Gunbarrel not sticking
forward just yet so he doesn't have that
information he's gonna try and use this
smoke to his advantage of fine the
player inside an IV but it's not gonna
work
another squeeky it's gonna be 16 to 7 in
the end two straight maps and the French
team will be the champions here in
Finland so in 2017 when they drop their
entire csgo roster it seemed like
Finland's time would never come but that
wasn't a reality that not too was
willing to accept in April 2018 just
before a straw were about to become the
greatest csgo team of all time and since
they had signed an all new all finished
roster one that they claimed would be
able to compete on the world stage
needless to say the community didn't
share and his enthusiasm CS fans had
been making fun events for years but it
wasn't until the announcement of this
roster that an old meme resurfaced to
haunt the Finnish organization once more
from the permafrost strikes a massive
hand the mythical giant once deemed dead
of the coast of Italy
now rises to life regenerated from
lambish soil the problem was that aside
from Oulu their entire roster was made
up of players who are either unknown
unproven first there were aerial in x7
who despite being in the scene for years
had never managed to crack into even the
mid-tier a professional play - thanks
I'm all about my own ESF and so forth
what ATS play well I thought it was a
feat in such a scheme i7 the just squeak
out the air instead of norrisville then
there was a Lexi B who had previously
played for ends before joining Finland's
other signature squad habu then rejoined
ends as their in-game leader most
promising perhaps was Sergei a 19 year
old player who had made a name for
himself on habu with alexei in the hands
of sergei of course this man is an
absolute meat grinder get the second
kill be site wide open there's no one
here to defend there is not a lot left
here for the Swedes they really need to
clean this up quickly but there it is
I'd like to get it and the fence take if
they defend the title of Nordic
champions to charge the road back to
back they are your champions but despite
being hailed as a prodigy he still
needed to prove himself on the world
stage and finally there's olive
he is the pride and joy of Finnish
Counter Strike and not you built ences
new roster around him would you say he's
also the inspiration of the team has to
be right I mean he's he's that the best
known Fitness he is there I would dare
to say like ever right and he's got a
lot of cool things on this career so I
think his uh he's a pretty cool guy to
look up to when you're playing with him
but I really enjoyed back there when I
played with him I could tell that this
guy's gonna be a star he had played for
both nip and phase and was known as a
player with an extremely high if
inconsistent piece it was a depressive
tranquilizer shot to his leg and Ali's
gonna follow that up with good kills in
fact on the RPK
that's essentially four in the round if
you want to credit bodies killed to him
but it's gonna be kioshima that closes
it out on shocks and a low again it's
just looking absolutely perfect and that
inconsistency was the problem
see sometimes although was the best
player on a server making
jaw-dropping plays it's just gonna take
a single good buzz
[Applause]
other times he looked like the worst
counter-strike player in the world
Tom's gonna go down apps we know come
tests towards that I'll be watching the
road tape what alley
given that there seemed to be no middle
ground for all of the community gave him
a nickname or two nicknames actually one
for each of his two extremes first
there's God all its way up slowly
unreal then there's really hitting his
consistency remember a few minutes ago
when I mentioned the actual shortest
round in csgo history it happened a few
years after the first and guess what hoe
gaat Behati again that is not a
coincidence keep in mind this map can go
t sided oh no it's the rush up middle
eco push I did not want to see that guys
that's that is that was tough that's
like watching adults beat up children
the man was and continues to be a
walking talking meme a living in nygma
and the thing is it's not just this play
that people find both perplexing and
entertaining it's his personality to
read about only for the commercials or
can you actually drink them going down
everyone the team keep it together I
know you're tired let's get this done
goes to every single one of them and so
I said oh he'll okay there's no that's
that's harsh but he was focused and I
was just trying to be a team a player
man so al you I've got to ask you this
and I want to kind of tell you right
away the MVP for this tournament by
Astro gaming is Sergey and I have to get
some words for you about this young
player he is a monster yeah
but for whatever reason this all
finished assembly of memed on misfits
defied every expectation then we have
and to the qualified team if so far
impressed us knocked out ni P in fact
not just knocked out but destroy the ni
p i mean there they tore the swedes a
new one after securing a top eight
finish at ESL one cologne in 2018 they
went on to win a string of miners and
qualifiers before finally earning their
first premier win at star series season
sets being game leader is getting back
up he's gets the opening kill
everybody's here to was to say bomb site
Alexi with two massive kills to follow
all the pressure on chopper he's going
to go down and ents have done it finally
they close finally they take them out
it's too easy for ents but it wasn't
until they won the Dreamhack winter
open two months later that people
started to think maybe they aren't such
a joke after all bomb three quarters of
the way gone all who confirming the
pushed upwards he knows the sonic here
it's the last man down and and we'll
take it I think this cements them in our
mind a justified invitation for 2019
it's just around the corner for this
team say it with me folks it's easy for
and
[Music]
still going into the cauda beats a major
and we're barely considered a top 10
team nobody expected them to make one of
the unlikeliest runs in csgo history and
dumpster top tier teams along the way I
don't want to rule them out completely
this is always a chance of an upset but
right now if from my standpoint it's
something pretty impulsive like right
yeah I agree I mean I don't want to be
able to mcglue because they had such a
phenomenal run to even be here right
down
Oh to down a map and oh seven in the
second map as not to said and they
somehow managed to crawl their way back
into this but liquids a whole nother
beast my team is just better
individually I think our tactics are
were together in cohesive right now
they're factor if they want to beat us
has to be either a low or Sergei going
on here we go
anybody with everything believing Sergei
to clean up for us back to the leech
both goes falling down that's to eat to
pays the last burn starving
you don't like to call these rounds but
the odds are so very low and he's got to
take so many Gamble's and none of them
are gonna pay off all the roses it is
this the end for liquid in Katowice I
lose 32 kills - his name's gonna - this
could be all she wrote the liquid 20
seconds left
Holly chipped it for a third
elective how do they build to put up the
biggest major feels [ __ ] awesome
vintage simple up against of new brand
of finish counter-strike our first map
trained us to lies in the wings as does
Mirage should we see three a semi-final
a Cinderella story unlike anything we've
witnessed in Katowice and eSports will
they continue their run yes a Cinderella
story but the clock strikes midnight vs.
Navi Ariel seems to know man I don't
think it will even if he dies earrings
to give away its position this is done
and
[Applause]
[Applause]
Zeus feature the deep breath
he got one with damping but will he get
one with Navi that's what he's wanted he
went back for a reason but insisted it
tonight the fins
[Applause]
what
unbelievable doesn't even cut their
dreams they really do come true a
project started in April of 2018 and a
dream run crafted in Katowice kings of
the minor pushed to the absolute brink
of elimination here at the major but
they ride through the turmoil and they
thrive versus the game's best ends in
the final of that very first major it's
gonna be a like huge task for us but we
have to believe in ourselves we believe
that we have a chance here in the major
to the final and we also have the chance
to take the final so let's go all the
way they have won everything recently
but are you look into their eyes you
know that they want this as well and if
you check the forum books the betting
you would know they are massive
favorites but that's what's been again
to the next team all the way through
this tournament
they are underdogs but they are here to
win please welcome to the stage
[Applause]
giving them so much space that a
stroller they catch him off except they
get the one kill they need that horses
do praise Him they picked it apart his
own gun I think blocks the vision and
now cynics knows that they're working in
one above all he's the lamb it's the
slaughter think of this dipping salute
perfection once again from Simba he's
about to close it out and a great effort
towards the end of that map an
astrologist too much to handle they have
to play it back to put everything into
it they've got to give themselves every
chance to believe in every possibility
they'll corner off Pacific's but devices
going around he's come one down already
he's isolated surveyed with a reload
reload to talk concern a hold on events
in their second
smiles on that face they should enjoy
every moment of this for these players
in their first major the grand final
against the world's best and this is
where it all ends
one more round will do it and won't they
punish one but it's just irritable fine
[Applause]
all right all right
and didn't beat a straw Louis but nobody
can beat a straw Louis and naturally
finishing second to them and a major is
about the best that anyone can hope for
yeah of course it's a it sucks after the
loss since we could have won it all you
mean but it has been an exhausting
journey this far and we're very proud of
that we are at least second and went
from minor winners to major grain
finalists and for one magical weekend
made it seem like anything was possible
they've shown that they can compete with
the top teams in the world we originally
thought of it as a top 15 team I think
we have to consider him a top five team
in the world after this major you might
have to change our tiers of teams the
remarkable thing is that their major
performance doesn't seem to be a fluke
and finished top three at blast Pro
serious out Paulo and have cracked the
top five in HL TV's world rankings since
the major position no great anticipation
of fallens peak he's the player on the
train and knows there's another in the
office he's just dancing around the
ladder he's being pitched though there
is a second player in taco trying to
find him
it's an olive are you kidding me this
would be the one before he did he did
after years of suffering Finland has
finally left their mark on CS goes and
world stage their theme is blossoming
like never before and it's all things to
ends turning a meme into reality the
expectations they've exceeded to get to
this point the counter-strike that
they've played ants have to be proud of
their effort you know they're gonna be
disappointed in the moment but they know
that they've just brought finished
counter-strike back towards the top
somewhere it hasn't been for years
so has not - achieved his dream of
turning Finland into a world-class csgo
powerhouse well no not yet but he's
getting a lot closer and so the chance
to do what luminosity and SK did for
brazillian CS they can galvanize an
entire region and if they can do that
the future is looking a lot brighter for
finished yes thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button